i'm afraid it is yet more terrible news
another really big jump in the rate of
inflation to 10.1 percent inflation was
in the 12 months uh to july 10.1 that is
the first time we have seen inflation in
double digits uh since
the 80s since the early 80s another
40-year high i say this every month and
we've been doing this for about 11
months in a row now 11 months in a row
we've had above target inflation we have
to remember the target that we would
like inflation to be about 2 so 10.1 it
really is huge and we are all feeling it
in our day-to-day lives there's some
real drivers to it it's food
it's fuel those are the two really
really big ones but what i think is
really frightening about this is we are
although it might not feel like it in a
slight calm before the storm moment at
the moment because when those energy
prices go up as they will in october um
things are going to get worse the energy
price cap i mean the forecast just
change every few days up and up could be
as bad as in excess of 4 000 pounds a
year in excess of 4 500 pounds a year by
the spring i mean really big numbers
we've had news today that the gas prices
in europe are going up again because of
the low levels of water in the rhine
people trying to
build up their stock so all of these
factors means things are probably going
to get a lot worse
in the in the in the autumn there could
well be a recession i hate to be such a
doom and gloom monger but but it really
is a bleak picture this morning